[Musique]
il y à 75 ans un géologue canadien lance
une idée révolutionnaire que la lune est
un morceau de la terre arraché lors de
l'impact d'une violence inouïe
début xxème siècle la lune est un monde
encore rempli de mystères
à preuve quand le cinéaste georges
méliès prend la tête d'une expédition
vers la lune
son imagination est sans limite la lune
cache bien des énigmes en particulier
celle de savoir d'où elle vient
[Musique]
à l'époque plusieurs idées circulent sur
son origine notamment que la lune était
un astres errants attraper au vol à
gravité de la terre
[Musique]
l'autre théorie en vogue ce éclatèrent
lors sa formation tournai si rapidement
qu'elle a projeté une partie d'elle-même
en orbite ce sera la source
d'inspiration du canadien original délit
mais il calcule que la rotation ne
suffit pas il imagine un scénario
catastrophe au moment où la terre est
tout juste formé une mini planète
la frappe de plein fouet du magma
s'envole dans tous les sens
puis les morceaux satire entre eux pour
former la lune délit s'appuie notamment
sur les photos disponibles à l'époque il
analyse minutieusement les cratères leur
taille gigantesque la hauteur des parois
des projections tout autour
[Musique]
tandis que ce ne sont pas des volcans
comme on croyait mais les cicatrices
d'impact à sa surface
et il a parfaitement raison mais il va
un peu trop loin
en concluant qu'il s'agit du dernier
morceau de la terre avoir rejoint la
green
on sait maintenant que les cratères ont
été formés sur des milliards d'années
par des comètes ou des astéroïdes qui
ont frappé la lune
[Musique]
pour le reste des hypothèses d'original
délits sont confirmées par les missions
apollo
les roches lunaires récoltés par les
astronautes sont très semblables à
celles de la terre
elles ont la même origine et 12 hommes
qui ont marché dans les traces des
explorateurs imaginé par médias n'ont
pas trouvé dans les cratères de la lune
des champignons énorme
ni le palais des sélénites mais plutôt
les indices des événements d'une rare
violence qui ont sculpté et paysages du
nerf d'une beauté à couper le souffle
[Musique]